so actually what happens when you think
about it you pay to be three times into
doing something dumb and two out of
three times I fell for it because
that's definitely what happened
yeah hello welcome today we've got a
little friend the game I played against
gods or Parker Parker who's like as of
when I played this game he was like rank
three or something so he's a really
strong terraforming Mars player so I
definitely had the better cards in this
game I feel like so if you're the one
with like five or ten points or
something and I gotta be honest I think
the pressure actually got to me a little
bit in this game which is kind of
embarrassing to admit because I'm a
grown man and just playing a friendly
game and who cares but needless to say
and without spoiling anything because
it's gonna be a really close game I
played the last couple of generations
absolutely horrible I don't know your
problem thinking well you just don't
want to admit that you're bad at the
game and no no no I I have a lot to
learn about this game but normally I'm
quite capable of actually planning out
my generation or just simply reading
numbers on the screen I couldn't even
read the numbers correctly but yeah it
was oh I was out of it that's all I'm
saying but that's good because it meant
it was a good learning experience for me
which means it's probably also got to be
a good learning experience for you so
I'm just gonna roll the clip of me
playing the entire game live and then
afterwards I'm gonna have a conversation
with Gods where we talked about all the
mistakes I made and then at the end of
the video I'm gonna come back bonus from
the future and then I'm gonna go through
all the mistakes that I noticed that I
made when I watched this replay and then
you know we can make it into a game
watch this game see if you can spot all
the mistakes like I just did and maybe
I'll find some mistakes that you didn't
find or you'll find some mistakes I
didn't find so yeah let's look at the
game and see you by the end of the video
so commercial District could make sense
but then I would have to
to go for biofuels
the biofuels or no I need the Science
Tech don't they I think I need the time
tag
I could take these two I think the good
players would probably take these two
but um I'm a greedy boy I want to go
but I think this is correct now that I
look at it oh man
so we do this this
this this
I mean it is still greedy right I can
just play this
then if you think about it I would be
forming a credit blockchain
for
one plan production but yeah
[Music]
I guess it's okay
this one article is a heat production
I think this is okay
yeah should we do this we do this
go for cards
full grid
oh what am I talking about I have energy
production here holy hell
ah screw this man I'm being greedy
I'll do this then
this this this this this this
is a very great game it's a bonus greedy
game let's go
all right
[Music]
so the ranking I I don't know yet it
might be a bit misleading because uh I'm
still new to ranked but I'm definitely
not at his level
so he's like 22-24 on this account I
think he even has several
others probably his main account
actually
but his last time I checked it was like
the second highest or the third highest
or something so the gods is really good
a terraforming Mass actually which is
really funny to me because I only know
Gods from playing DOTA and watching him
he's like one of the big casters he's
been to lots of the ti which is the
world championship of DotA
so that's where I went from so it's very
funny to meet him here
but uh I'm I'm just gonna like disregard
everything these guys taught me and I'm
gonna just got a base play Super greedy
so it should be interesting
so
pretty standard some terraforming
see what I get here
the virus is actually huge you look
illogical concern as well
okay
so he's just going for a standard and
the game really fast game that's what's
happening
so I have 22 so I think I just play this
since I'm breeding but yes heat
production which is lucky for me
it is actually a little bit risky to be
honest but I'm playing on my opponent I
guess because I know these guys are
going pretty much
so I might as well just remove that
yeah it looks good
it looks good YOLO
[Music]
but do I want the plants do I want
I guess I could just put it here
but then I'm once again playing their
game this is playing my game taking the
card but playing their game is taking
the plans but
I don't know I think I have to take
plans here
I think Lance is correct I'm not sure
I'm definitely restricting this area so
it's not terrible
so now I just have to keep track of his
plans I can virus him next German
actually it seems really good to me and
then I play business Network
so I think I might even have two attacks
I think I could even do this
I mean I am YOLO
let's go
I might even take Vesta Shipyard
even though I know I shouldn't but oh
[\h__\h] I am actually I am seven systems
in that case I'll take whatever comes
back here I think it's fine
well I have to take this just so he
doesn't get it but noctis is also
tempting oh no I should have taken the
titanium first Jesus
now I have to take this but then he gets
noctis but there's still one point for
me so
yeah I have to do it like this
it's still okay
I'm getting some engine I could keep
this just for the point but I don't
think he's gonna
ah so what is this one point two points
with this
probably even more but can I forward it
let's see 6 26 so I can play this for
eight one Mega credit production
that's 18. I want to play this I want to
play yeah that's basically it I don't
have much else to play actually
you know I could actually play it
just go full YOLO
it's not terrible
uh I have to virus right yeah yeah for
sure
[Music]
and then I play
space hotels and I'll meet a group yeah
all right
you don't want to end the game so this
is a classic game what I'm used to
playing that I want to play the long
game and he wants to close early that's
definitely what it is right now
so let's see what I get worms is
interesting but
it I have two wildtex actually it could
give me like two plant production but is
it too greedy to keep worms
tough sure tough call I think it might
be too greedy
I kind of want to
uh 12 20 I can play these two if I don't
pick up worms so no
I'm not gonna pick it up
yeah he's doing the ocean rebates thingy
now he's setting up to convert next-gen
I think
it's hard to say
I guess I'll just have to see if I can
get some plantain or something
planet is very good for me I still need
the science text I need cop draw I need
a lot of things
also have to look at the milestones
so this looks interesting but I don't
have steel production
no way to get steel
he doesn't either
take away cloud seeding
I don't know it feels funny just to
cloud seating just to mess up his uh his
seat production
I don't hate it but it's not really a
good play to be perfectly honest
I think cloud seeding will come back I
think I'll take the best card here
uh there's no way he takes space
elevator like that's literally no way
I think I'll do this
the worst case scenario is it takes is
he takes this cloud seating but I don't
think it's a it's a really good card so
I have eco
I have the amplifier for plans so I'll
take this The Logical tone
and that looks fine
there's no way I take that I don't think
of water myself either
did I pick up no I didn't pick up so
this is
it's a little bit desperate to be honest
but I mean I have very little else to do
this generation
I actually have nothing to do
foreign
I think I'll take it just because I have
very little little to do
okay
well the good news for me is it's not
very efficient what he's doing but it
might still be winning I don't know
so he could
not imagine
Lang claim
I kind of hate this card but I think
it's good for this part here
17 gold I might as well just take it
I think it's okay
mining area okay
yeah
so since I committed to this trash I
might as well play it
who knows maybe I'll get a
some card to bumpy but it is not a good
play
um
not crazy about this this card
might as well play this
Pros are telling me that apparently heat
production is good so
could give me like one point doing the
game
I run into
the hacker thingy
the energy hacker thingy but I think
it's still
worth the risk
I still only have one science tank which
is annoying
uh
foreign
would be what I usually would think
about getting in this position but
it's also very inefficient but for my
situation it makes me do a conversion so
it's not terrible actually this one I
kind of want but I think this will come
back to me I think it's gonna take
one of the others I'm guessing
yeah
everyone on the Discord hates hackers so
I kind of want to play it just for this
reason
[Music]
but I think the cities I don't know
this needy is not that good either to be
honest but it makes me convert at least
when I convert I can play my eco Zone
which is annoying for him
I think I'll just steal Thunder
and I take this because of the science
tag I think yeah I think it's good
enough
[Music]
I'm getting something it's not terrible
he's doing like all and terraforming
I should have a lead here but I'm I'm
not sure
we keep to under farming I could just
because I have ecos ecological sign
but if I keep this and this that 30 and
then I want to convert
anything else I want to do this Jen
not really to be honest
[Music]
I think this looks okay
so I can't really burn his plants
[Music]
I kind of want to just take two
um plants maybe here even
well I could check this actually that'd
be disgusting wouldn't it oh
it could take its rebate here and just
convert next to him and make him be
really sad about his life
oh
I like I like
I like making God really sad about his
life
that is actually cool
but then again it's gonna be
it's gonna be like a three-point City I
guess it's not bad to be honest you know
what I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it
I don't need it
so three five seven oh [\h__\h] I can't even
do math I don't have a conversion if I
do this
what the hell am I doing
three fun five to seven oh my God
that sucks
I guess I have to do this
nah well
I mean I could just to get a sign attack
but I really don't feel good about it
[Music]
nah I don't think I wanted
it's not that important
I could just find here to be honest 32.
uh
foreign
my whole reason for keeping this idios I
thought it was okay because it could
convert
but apparently simple math is
beyond my capabilities
I might still just take the city to be
honest
[Music]
ah
it's so terrible
why don't I have one more plant
no
no the issue is I don't even know how to
get one plant
Valley Trust is cool
that also changes my plan a little bit
now I think I have to build the city
here
I just hope he doesn't have plantain I
mean he has two cars to be honest
you can really keep planted because of
two cards
I don't believe so but I can't know for
sure
so he's probably gonna pass now I'm
thinking
but I'm not sure
you know what I have nothing else I
might as well
no I should wait until I convert right I
should really wait
ah
[Music]
so I need something to give me two plans
or maybe I just never play this I just
don't play it at all
it's kind of funny he's like playing so
many standard projects
kinda like it
well that's a science thing
nuke Zone
is good but there's no way I say no to
this right
nobody got any energy production
so there's some Duke Zone and the other
two are dead cats happy horse is cool
lava flows is cool
I don't think I gave Happy Rose to
ecoline that seems dangerous
and then this is these are dead cards
it's like this probably
it's okay
thank you
I have to get one award I have to get
Builder or planner
but he got no cities I don't think he's
getting Builder
but I'm helping in terraform by giving
him this maybe it was not good
so the issue is I have the same problem
as I had the last generation I have very
little to do
special designs could be cool
but not really
I don't think I want it
so he's taking two actions I should take
two actions
I think the the difference now is that I
can start the next Generation converting
which is probably what I should be doing
I guess
so I
I know he has noctis right
so I could
I could just take this maybe
foreign
this game is not progressing as well as
I wanted to
I gotta be honest he might actually he
might beat me just for playing standard
projects I don't like this
I have so bad cards
I might stand up project something
would be okay
I think City and standard project
Greenery
and then I can
convert and maybe steal this somehow
I mean I have so much gold I have so
little to do
hello works now
um
you know what let's go for it
24 23.
I think this is okay because I can
convert immediately
foreign
[Music]
ery I mean he's not gonna build my plans
I played virus already
now he's got Gardener okay so he could
see that I was making a play for Gardner
but I I think I'm also making a play for
the uh
for the bonus to be honest
I think that's more what I'm doing
might as well take this one
there's no reason not to
there should be a plant there
uh
I think I'll do this
then do this
and then ecozone here is maybe actually
good yeah
I think ecosome there makes a lot of
sense then I can
so Builder I'm one-off Builder no
actually I have Builder okay
yeah okay so Builder is the one whilst
that I'm getting this game that's good
enough
and there's no rush right he's gonna get
this and nothing else there's no rush
shouldn't be
Mangrove could be a thing
oh actually this is really good right I
have to take this
[Music]
and I don't think they want catapult
these guys do not want
and to be honest at this point I
probably don't want it either
but this makes me convert it's really
good
a little bit of plantain as well but I
think I'll take this first and then I'll
take mining's position on Mangrove
oh yeah Central well
definitely taking that
he doesn't know that I I have this many
science tanks
okay so I have
one two three
and yeah AI Central is four so I have
what I need for Quantum extractor as
well even without search life
so think do this I want conversion can I
get air central down this gen
it's kind of rough
not if I convert
[Music]
maybe it's close to be honest
Mangrove could be a bit greedy
but I have herbivores I don't know
I think I'm keeping too many cats
so one two three I can do a central next
gen and now I steal each bonus here and
then I have to pick up the Milestone as
well
and then I can do air central Milestone
next gen
I think that's okay to be honest
[Music]
so do I keep mangrove
I really want to
it is like three points for 12. I think
it's still worth it
also
so I'm gonna take since I'm considering
I'm me I'm probably gonna take the card
here
and then I do one conversion
because that's gonna mess up his uh
water
thingy
yeah I think that's good
so take the cards here I'm gonna take
three plants
and then I convert to get the bonus
I'll take this spot here I think it's
good
and that's the last piece of
terraforming I'm gonna do
until the game ends by the way I'm just
gonna
never play herbivores never play my
plans
I'm gonna just play Olympus conference
yeah Central just go for the long game
it's even questionable to help him end
the game like this but uh
it is what it is
well he's not gonna get the last one
surely he's not gonna get the last one
I think I could wait a while I think
actually I should find some of this I
should fund Banker right
yeah I should find Banker
so let's see I can draw first
this is also bushes I want to play
Zeppelins no thank you
now I have to I have to get this this
and this is enough
so this is
31 plus four can I even get it though
[Music]
wait a minute
uh this and this
is 31.
so I only need to sell one card actually
oh Leo
it's a little bit risky because he's
gonna start next gen but I don't think
he's gonna nah man he's not gonna take
Builder from me there's no way
[Music]
you know what I think that's good enough
I have to I have to play a central when
I can right
there's no way
I don't have energy I'm such an idiot oh
my God
oh the stupid City oh no I knew that was
a mistake
in that case I shouldn't uh
uh man
that's so awkward
in that case I should probably play my
plant tags and just get this uh
one of these things I think scientist is
safe
I think
like
Bankers safe
right
scientists should be super safe
like he should have zero right
I still have one I guess one two
three four
I think I found scientists
and then I just play some plant tags
here
[Music]
thank you
I could sell one card to get Legend down
but do I really want Legend in my
position
I'm not even sure play this card to be
honest if this goes to eight I lose if
this goes to nine I lose Maybe
I don't think I don't think I want
Legend
I think I'll just play this
maybe just pass
you could sell something
I don't think passing is fine
I think that is fine
so I'm definitely winning Builder it's
just a matter of when I should pick it
up
more here production for him more ending
the game for him I think water is gonna
end the game to be honest
it's still five for water
I think definitely have to cut water
cards what can you do you get something
back on events but this is still late it
feels like
I think water's the last one to end this
is not a big deal
industrial center yeah who cares
maybe I think I need the energy myself
let's take this but then I help him end
which is not good
at that Legend
foreign
so I think I have to take it because of
the energy production oh actually I
complete this and play this
right
one two
three four that makes more sense
[Music]
another game where I play Early
breathing filters feels good
I think that's what I have to do to be
honest
so I don't think I keep deep will hating
that also just helps him end the game
Legend I don't I don't keep anything to
be honest
right half a point here but
I don't think it has much value
yeah all right
foreign
I don't like this at all
but at least he's not touching my
milestones and Banker should also be
mine
he has some gold
I think he wants to
it kind of feels like if I just play
landlord I win the game but I'm not sure
landlord thermalist he could do a
thermalist
he could for sure do thermalists
I think Banker makes sense
Banker but I don't know I also have an
expensive plan here
yeah
I'm not sure
I think I just play my cards it's good
enough
[Music]
one two three
four
LG okay
and just down to two cards again
another chance this is mine this is mine
I think at the start of the Next
Generation I'm gonna phone Banker
but let's see what hey essential gives
me if I've if I have enough cash I might
actually play Cows here
also Thunder farming is a thing it's
under calming farming might be better
than cows
I'm not taking this bonus you can have
it
what I'm gonna do is bring fill this and
oh telling your comment is cool
and column extractor
[Music]
then I'm gonna play air central
that's pretty much it
so he has to end the date if he doesn't
end the need I think I win
[Music]
but I don't think you can do it
decomposers
herbivores
something like this there's also this is
I have some water cards if I want to go
that way but it kind of feels like I
need to force him to close the game
so you cannot take planner you cannot
Builder
we just have to get my
well I cannot say no to kill farming
around I think that's too good to pass
up even even for my grid
and then I hope endangered workers comes
to me but I'm not sure
large Convoy School
that's a lot of points actually
is kind of cool but
I don't think it's better than this I
think that's called voice just straight
up better
[Music]
it's annoying so many water cards here
not happy to see that at all
greenhouses is like one I don't know why
I kept that that was unnecessary but
this is still worth it though
I don't think so
I think it's like half a point and one
plant right
it's not enough
to justify spending nine gold on this
I think this and this and I
I try to play my hand and try to go for
Gen 9 the Gen 10.
I think that's how I have to play
yeah it's it's ah I don't know maybe
even this is too greedy
but I kind of want to
I mean it didn't play cow last gen so
I'm already playing car now I think it's
still worth it
I think I do cow but no greenhouses
I have to play it now though so this
generation is pretty much cow killed
farming
draw a bunch of cards
also have to fund
and I maybe also have to pick up the
Milestone depending on what he does but
I think this is correct it feels wrong
man uh
normally I would take I would say
greenhouses but in this game I don't
think I can do it
I think I do this it's okay
so may uh build a
I mean yes how many cats four cards uh
he's not taking Builder from me he's not
gonna take this from me either I don't
think
so I'll do this
and unfortunately I don't have a comment
[\h__\h] the correct play was to draw to see
if I could get a comment but at the same
time
if I do that then uh also
I'm open to funding something so
and I'm also closing the game which I
don't know what to do so I think he'll
take the bonus that's a little I can do
about it
he's not going to though at least not
yet
now the city kinda looks better maybe I
should have kept this city
so now he's baiting me into taking the
award do I wondered
kind of don't think I'd do
I mean it is a water oh my God
I would hate not taking this water
when he's offering it but I think it is
a bait I think he wants me to take it so
I help him close the game
but I think this game should be over
either way
[Music]
I think I'll just play
you can post a skill time something like
this
and then also the cow if I want to play
the cow I have to play it now how much
is this
livestock yikes
13. I have loan so livestock kelp
farming alone that seems good
I think that's all I should do
good enough
I might not even play herbivores this
game
it might just be be bad
yeah this makes sense
oh so this is actually a point for me
right
I think this small thing is actually the
point for me
that's funny
I think I'll just go a little let's see
what's happened
so right now I have
if I really want to play livestock I
have to sell three cards
which is not cool
alternatively I can
I don't know
I played Four he played Four this means
nothing
I could even large Convoy just on some
smaller animal I think if I don't play
livestock now I don't play it at all so
I can just
oh I don't like this
but I think Guild farming is better than
livestock to be honest
Guild farming Turtle farming
symbolic
fungus it's kind of like a point if I'm
not mistaking
I have so many cards in my hand I want
to play it's a bit greedy what I'm doing
I might not play my job units either
I might though it's still five points
for this
six points if I play the other one
I don't think I'm playing livestock this
game
maybe I'm saving it for next gen in case
I have money but I don't think I have
so I can sell something I can sell like
lichen
just to clean up a little bit
[Music]
you're selling three cards everything
just so I can get
I mean this is one point but getting the
cows down now is also one point
capital is only if my banker gets in
trouble
[Music]
right that's no I mean there's three
points here but it doesn't really feel
necessary
is there any point in oh does this work
with this
[Music]
Jesus doesn't work with my
it might media archives
for evil no it's not tag right forever
event ever played no I don't think it
works
there's one girl to be had by playing
media aircrafts now but I can also wait
and get three gold
so do I play cows or do I just forget
about cows and just play the uh microbe
the microbe might be
what I should do oh okay he's setting up
to and text him yeah that makes sense
but Kenny though that's a question
[Music]
I think we kinda even
there's no way you're still building
text in hand I don't think
so let's see how much this goes
chaos is one point if I play it now and
then it is another three points
let me just sell some water or something
and then it's like another three point
so that's one and a half point I get is
it four
it's actually Four
oh man I think one of the cows now
that'll look at it
this is like one point but it could also
be one point next gen
no we couldn't have to play now ah
the greedy way to do it but to be to
play
this now
and then
because there's one here
I don't know
it feels like it shouldn't be correct I
could also just sell my towel at this
point
[Music]
if I'm not playing this now I'm selling
it so I have to I have to choose between
these two it's really rough
I think livestock is slightly better
so Mangrove he's gonna get the last
available Tiana which sucks but
you just want to live I think livestock
is what I have to do here
but do I even keep do we even play this
for four points is the other question
maybe I don't don't play livestock or
large Conway
six punch though
and two cuts
oh
no I think I think I'll just play
lifestyle it's good enough it's okay
so I do this play livestock
foreign
[Music]
scientists doesn't matter
uh he has no tax
underground city doesn't matter
I think immigrant City just for cheap
City could make sense
yeah
that's the only thing that makes
innocence right now this I don't want to
play against
insects you can have I don't care
I also like one Greenway fan oh man
so for sure it's gonna burn my plans if
I let him so three plants versus
like
like an entire Greenery oh my God
but then also help him end which I don't
want
ah
these are not cards I want to see right
now
[Music]
insects is very good for me though
to say
insects immigrant City and have a lot of
points but
[Music]
I still have too much stuff in my hand I
want to play I have cards that gives me
six points
I don't think I'm keeping insects I
think he has to has to do it the
question is also can he actually keep
insects and also close the game right
now
because he has to he has to close the
game at night if you can't close the
game right now I win I think I win
anyway but I'm not sure
but if he doesn't in right now I'll win
for sure like no question
foreign
so do I want to play my amplifier that's
like 4.5 points
I think I don't play asteroid managers
audio I might play large Convoy and the
amplifier
but I don't know it really depends if
he's going to end the game right now
I think immigrant seat is correct in any
case
it's just too many points
[Music]
is it three points for 16.
I'm not entirely sure
let's see if the game drags on
he has to prove that he can close the
game right now so one two
one two three one so that's he doesn't
have standard projects or anything
so that's 23 and three times 40.
so that's 42
and 23
huh 42 isn't it yeah 42
3 so that's 55.
the heating clothes actually [\h__\h] it's
it's definitely the last generation
I just have to figure out how to
overtake any points
which should not be too difficult
I hope
I need to play one more to get some
points here I need to play one more
because of the no actually I have to
decompose I need to play one more for
ecological time
I need to look at my plants
you should take the last two O2 bumps I
don't know what he's thinking about you
should definitely take this and this
like there's no question
I really don't know what he's thinking
about
oh he didn't ah he's baiting me he's
beating me again
but I mean it's uh
what the hell does he want to play like
see now
theater
14 23 it's 55 he can close the game why
is he giving me this last conversion
I really don't understand this
that is so strange to me
that must be a really good card in his
hand he wants to play
I I know that he can close the game if
he wants to like for sure
so I don't know I'm taking this I
believe I'm the winning even if I take
this right
because it's eight
I think I am
[Music]
a flip bank or something now I think I
would straight up winning
if I just get the last conversion
so the last conversion is interesting I
can get it here and then I have just
enough plans around Mercedes I think
that could make sense this also makes
sense
because of the plants I have right now I
have for a conversion of the extra round
if I play Thunder farming in Casey burns
my plants I have a little bit extra
I don't know man I think this is great
immigrants it is just too good
[Music]
so I'm never playing herbivors by the
way that wasn't a mistake
I am a little bit too greedy it would
seem
to me it feels like it really
player is going to win this in nine
generations for the record
but let's see if I'm correct these were
standard projects yeah
I don't want to do this you can you can
he can do that himself
what do I want to do I think I just want
to chill and just throw some cards
it's no rush doing anything
[Music]
it's 65.
he might actually be winning am I stupid
foreign
I'm getting tilted if he wins eight
points
you can do one more
[Music]
14. he cannot do one more
so now he has to choose either to close
the game
or I mean he has to just close the game
that's no question just has to
so he's gonna be at 19 so he cannot make
another Greenery
so um I know that this is gonna be score
right
how to what the hell how did you get
this no
oh [\h__\h]
I did not expect this how did he have
this much cash what did I miss
80 points [\h__\h] I'm actually lost oh my
God that's so bad
all right
let's see
I should have started the last award
Maybe
no I couldn't I couldn't have
oh man if I lose this it's such a throw
so this is six points I think I have to
play this
[Music]
oh my God what I'm doing
I'm actually I'm actually tilting
I'm playing so poorly right now
yeah I threw this Jesus Christ
I threw this heart
uh maybe I'll win on gold actually
I might win on gold here
all right so I'm definitely selling some
cards now I'm selling this
I can still play my amplifier but I
don't think it's enough
Jesus Christ
I might have just lost just by
yeah of course I'm losing there's no way
I'm playing this holy hell what am I
doing
yeah I'm definitely lost Jesus
I'm not sad that I lost but upset that I
thought I had this
it's a little bit embarrassing
definitely too greedy I cannot I cannot
be this greedy against these guys
I have to be a little bit less greedy
but I couldn't have found it actually I
could maybe I should have found a
thermalist on one
I'm not sure
yikes yikes CX
also might have given him this last
award by making the greenery
so that's a swing of two but that's a
swing of three
oh my God
what a terrible performance by me
foreign
this was winnable for sure
[Music]
just get too many cuts
all right
this was winnable I don't think my
strategy was wrong my execution was
definitely wrong I think I think I
should have won this for sure
hey
okay yeah did you even
very close
uh I feel like I should have won this
for sure yeah I think you should
definitely win this yeah
um even the last venue I think you made
a huge mistake converting for one thing
yeah I was I was wondering this a lot
like I was thinking well you're gonna
convert you're gonna close the game but
then uh yeah after right after I
converted I I immediately thought [\h__\h]
now I actually opened the possibility of
him starting a uh an award that's what
you're wearing where are you doing it
right yeah
I mean I had exact cash to finish so I
was always exciting so I think your
reasoning is oh I'll take a green right
away because you can end anyways yeah
yeah I know by doing that you saved me
21 cash so that 21 cash gets me landlord
I think it's it's okay to convert if you
instantly funded an award but you I mean
you didn't really have an award like
minor I think I was a head-on and
thermalist I think you're ahead by one
so maybe you could find thermalists
there I guess you can because you see I
have no cards so I think you could have
funded thermalists and you just win yeah
even if there's no award by you taking
it you let me SP a city which SP
Greenery is like one okay I get the TR
which is one point well I guess I guess
SB greenier is three points because I
steal it I steal the TR plus The Greener
itself is one point so it's like a
three-point play but a city if you if
you take it I can still SP city which is
also three points so
yeah I guess it's the spring of two
points but that would still be enough
because if you don't SP Greenery you you
take the water instead so that's let's
say that's the same cost so you get five
points or the or three points like
you're saying I think you played nrb
really early which I think didn't score
very well for you and which one
uh the nitrogen Rich bacteria I think
that car was pretty weak to play early
on yeah it gave me it gave me two points
it could have made it three points I had
a card to to enable it by the end but I
chose to do something yes
but it was either that or just do
nothing with my gold I had a week a week
mid game there was nothing I could do
yeah I think yeah I would lean more
usually towards just doing nothing and
saving your cash yeah I think so it's a
lot of money to get two points for 14
for two points yeah it's not the most
efficient it's not like terrible like I
mean it wasn't really 14 because you get
I guess immediately yeah you probably
paid like you know 12 or 13 12 to 13 or
even less yeah you get one money prod
right away so maybe it was only like
eight or nine for two points but I had
an amplifier for six points so I don't
know I somehow I somehow believed a lot
of throughout the game that it was gonna
go to to yeah and I should be I should
be okay I'm definitely winning if it
goes to 10 but I should be still okay if
it goes to nine but I think I just I
kept too many cards
I think playing AI felt incredibly weak
it was gen 7 so you only got to use it
three times you play research
coordination filters and Quantum is like
a terrible card to play you got like
nothing from Quantum yeah I guess it
maybe secures you it meant I couldn't
get serverless like theoretically you
actually could have funded thermals
because of it but like like Quantum is
just a terrible card to play there it's
just like stick
ing 13. it was weak but I have this uh
when I see something greedy I was like
oh man I have I have to be greedy yeah
but uh I even said it out loud in my
stream it's like uh AI Central probably
yeah a little bit too late especially
when you know I'm rushing like when you
play that's such a big cash investment
to score like hardly any points unless
you find like the absolute like most
insane cards yeah you're right
you did I think it was Gen 5 or
something I mean I thought you was a
free bump but because you had a
conversion the next gen without it you
could have just oh if I don't know
if I don't convert you have to convert
right
which which so you're talking about the
bump if I don't get the bomb you're
getting the bomb for sure in that
generation yeah but I think that's okay
like because
I mean I I don't think you care about
the bump in that situation so much it
was kind of like the same way you don't
care about me getting the ocean bump
because you don't want to help me end
like I was like oh if you want to take
this ocean take it yeah yeah I also call
it because at the end oh my God yeah at
the end I was asking Greenery so you
kind of just helped me and by it so
actually what happens when you think
about it you paid it be three times into
doing something dumb and two out of
three times I fell for it because
that's definitely what happened yeah
because you had like the seven plants
but you had one prod so you could have I
think what you should do there is just
pass with seven plants and you open with
conversion and then ecozone me
um yeah and then I don't care about bump
yeah yeah and then you just you just
give me the I mean I had no I actually
had like no plants there like it would
have cost me like I was asking during
this because I had the whole game I had
like two or three plant prod until I got
algae online I had no plant prod yeah
there's no way I I help you close the
game I thought it was so early in the
game I had literally like fought a cash
I couldn't spend on anything so I
thought it was okay to make this play to
deny you a little bit as well but I
don't think if I just wait because then
it goes to 10 and then I win for sure
even just that last year and I think if
you I think converting was fine just
needed to find oh I mean I guess you see
I think
I also messed up by me I made a mistake
because I sold my two cards and once I
sold my two cards I realized I should
have
um taken landlord right away I think I
was worried about Saba maybe and if you
stabbed me that I couldn't speak
asteroid but yeah
um once I sold my two cards I gave you
another chance to fund thermalists and
you know at that point you know you're
up plus one on thermalist and you can be
like oh yes
if I was a hidden thermalist I
completely uh yeah you're up one heat I
had I think I had seven heat prod and
you had I had or six or seven heat
product and you were had one because of
your energy from Quantum you were up
plus one
is to just do nothing there uh if if I
like
okay so I could have just found it like
forget all the math we were just talking
about the typewracks and everything it
was just fun 10 minutes I went oh my God
yeah exactly you just fun thermal yeah
exactly don't worry about the tiebreak
abuse well that I think that only
happened because I messed up I shouldn't
have sold my cards because I didn't need
the two cash the reason I sold them is
because I thought I was going to
SP City into asteroid and I had exact
cash for that but then I realized wait a
second landlord's just better than this
since I have
I had to calculate a bit first because I
thought maybe you could find landlord
but then you were like you were too far
behind yeah
ah that was not good yeah that was
definitely a mistake for me though yeah
which was a pretty big a pretty big
mistake if you saw that you had thermal
aside I just lose
yeah I was uh it was one of those games
where I had a lot of bad plays also made
a lot of bad plays just because I felt
like I had nothing better but I think
it's the wrong way so I made the city in
the beginning which was also
questionable I should have made a
mistake there I only kept the city
because I thought I could convert
immediately but other than that in the
the Dome one yeah the dome for the
expensive city that gives you three
plants oh yeah yeah that seemed okay to
me because it was gonna you had ecozone
so you wanted to get a conversion I
think it was
a big maybe it cost you as well and you
took asteroid over insects in the last
draft that didn't make sense to me I
just didn't want you to get it right
because you were trying to end the game
so you wanted to burn my plants
and did you ever play insects because I
don't think I wanted to play n6 myself
but did you play it okay I guess it's a
green review so it's two points because
you had like six points yeah I had
stupid cards in my I had a German
amplifier for six uh for six points so
so I I wasn't looking yeah anything else
that's true if insects isn't good for
you I mean I guess then that's fine but
I don't I guess I have Media Group so
theoretically asteroid is the same as SP
asteroid
okay yeah that makes sense actually
um yeah I wasn't I don't even know if
maybe you could pay it off for me but
um with Media Group I guess yeah cutting
asteroid makes sense and then if I have
any other titanium cards I can use the
titanium although like I I knew I didn't
even want to answer I mean I calculated
my plan so I saw that if you burn three
of my plants I might not be able to
convert so why why not cut the asteroid
I think
I'm also gonna love about that one I'm
bothered about the AI Central and uh
what's it called quality extractor yeah
the AI I think was a massive
[Laughter]
I think the SP Greener was a massive
mistake as well
as well I'd say those two like don't do
either of those and you probably win
here yeah I mean if you don't do the SP
or anything I never end the game
yeah Central stuff didn't affect me
ending the game but
and then yeah the end stuff with the
fund it was obviously I thought I had a
great start and then I mean gen 1 heat
Trappers and Gen 2 virus gave you like
with your Productions almost winning all
the game I was I was yeah I was sure is
against the rush setup is like the best
card in the game like
cripples me but the fact I could still
end gen 9 I mean I had a chance yeah I
was like for half a second or third ah
maybe I shouldn't what if it doesn't go
here production what am I talking about
I'm playing against you guys you're
always going
yeah yeah I mean sometimes you never
know what they have what the hand is but
that definitely when I saw Eco lime with
GHC factories I was like okay easy eco
line yeah I was also not sure about the
my opening hand I I picked this preload
um
and then I picked this card you just
mentioned that burns your hip production
they're going between me one energy to
production and I use that immediately to
get
down uh commercial District yeah
commercial District I wasn't sure about
that play either but it felt like it was
either that or just to pass the first
generation
yeah I mean I was taking a few notes and
that was one of the first things I put
was like commercial District seems a bit
iffy but probably okay like you had such
high production
um it meant I actually didn't want to
buy not this city because yeah excited
I was also debating getting the card of
the plants and I was like nah I have to
get the plans here and then yeah I was
happy when I saw knock the city and I
was like do I pick this up and like nah
I'll let you I'll let you suffer no no
yeah it's just a useless car I actually
think it was I made a mistake I probably
should have just I think I was worried
about passing I was never gonna play it
but I didn't want to pass it to you
um I but then I passed you Birds instead
but I guess you never played birds in
the end
I had a big decision playing
cows or
or the one that gave me one
one micro per turn that would give me
like one points for four
and I choose to sell like three cards so
I can play Cows just because I had the
um
but if I had probably done the math
maybe I should have realized I couldn't
play both uh
what's it called
the big the big Comet from your the
large Convoy yeah yeah large Convoy I
couldn't play both large Convoy and my
amplifier so I think I was debating
whether to just sell cows and sell the
large Convoy
and then just uh go for for my job in
amplifier which was also six points so
it's kind of the same
yeah
actually I think I mean did you have I
had two jovians and then I had two
wildtex and then I had the the one that
gives based on how many tags I have
right now you know oh you had the
terraforming Ganymede yesterday yeah
yeah
Five Points so technically it's actually
not as good as the the other one but
then I didn't have to play Cows I don't
know man
yeah anyway these are these are small
things the biggest thing is like the
missus in the last generation that was
yeah yeah
I mean the biggest thing is yeah I think
playing how you played the last gen
playing AI Central and then also the
this shouldn't you should be able to
drag this to gen10 yeah took 302 bumps
so that just gave me like that saved me
you know 70 cash right there so
um like I I was not even close to being
able to engine 9 without that
like the Gen that I was just asking
every Greener because I was like the
sooner I asked me this Greener I get one
cash prize so I was like I'm gonna SP
every Greenery I can
but you did good like cutting me off on
rebates like you know the other that
early land claim I got it everything you
did in the first couple days just like
I'm gonna lose this game yeah
I thought so too I thought so too but
apparently I'm still
like I'm able to throw on unusable games
which is uh blocking me a little bit
so good it was it was unranked so no
punishment oh I don't care man
I just uh I get mad at myself for for
making such mistakes but it was very
nice yeah it was fun so thanks for the
game yeah you too thanks for the game
all right see you see ya hello I'm back
let's look at everything I did wrong
this game
first of all I started off this game a
bit weird I went for a bunch of Mega
credit production which is not bad but I
did play this commercial District right
next to inductor City so I don't think
it's that bad it's just my style of play
I I like having Mega credit production
but at the same time I think the tempo
nerds would tell you that it's a little
bit questionable at the least because
I'm paying one annual day production and
a bunch of make credits just to get four
Mega credit production and I didn't have
any steel to pay with this either but
looking at my hand I don't think it's
that bad because I really didn't have
that many good plays to go for here and
also later on he actually had the chance
to get knocked the city but he didn't
want to go for it because I had
commercial District right next to it so
there's that then I kept space hotels
over where's the shipyard which is very
questionable given that I'm sets on
systems so it's in terms of value it's
like almost the same of course the space
hotels is better because it's four Mega
credit production versus one Mega credit
production and one titanium production
but at the same time I had one amplifier
in hand and there's one point on Vista
Shipyard by itself so it is like two
points out the window it's I don't makes
no sense to be aware of this you know
what it is I think it's my brain just
realizing all right I have two Earth
tags I can play Space hotels there's
only generation two this is amazing
let's go and then I didn't stop to think
about vestershire would have been better
for me and then also kept asteroid mine
Consortium which is weird because my
opponent didn't have any titanium
production so I know there's like again
just like where's the ship you have this
like two points at the end of the game
but it's rather expensive I can find
something else that's also two point by
the end of the game which is a card that
doesn't have to drag my hand the entire
game so I don't know it's ways agree to
keep this card just for the VP aspect of
it because yes if I get more amplifiers
that's a world where I can give you even
more points but at the same time as of
right now it will only give me two
points so it's really not worth keeping
so early it's it's not a good idea now
let's talk about Dome crater first of
all I picked up this city which is
questionable and I knew this when I
played it but it's it's like the same as
commercial District I didn't really have
much to do and secondly I actually
thought it would give me a conversion so
this is like the first sign that I I was
literally turning off my brain this game
because I thought that two plants plus
two plants plus three plants would
actually give me a conversion but no
that's only seven plants which means
that he's gonna start the next
Generation so maybe he can burn all of
my seven plans and you know I could have
played the city one generation before
but this is debatable once again because
I'm a little bit scared that he will
burn my plants and so on so this is one
of those games that he just wants to
close the game as soon as possible so if
he gets away without closing it like
generation a to generation 9 then he's
gonna have a good chance of winning
otherwise if it goes longer in 10th
Generation so then I'm gonna win and
normally I'm very aware of these things
but in this game I just didn't think
about it for some reason so here for
example I just let him have nuclear Zone
and lava flows I'm not sure he's gonna
use lava flows but he's definitely gonna
use nucleus here he's probably gonna use
both to be honest so I should have
caught both of these cards I don't know
why I didn't and then there's a small
mistake here I played Heather before I
played ecozone and this one I can
understand that I made this mistake
because in the moment it felt like I
needed this plan to actually make a
conversion because I need a conversion
to get Eco Zone down but then what I
ended up doing is buying a standard
Greenery for 23 so I might as well done
that before and then equal soon and then
hither that would have been the correct
sequencing but I mean even then why do I
even like pay this standard Greenery I'm
just helping him to close the game I
don't know why I did it I did it because
you know I wanted to take this bonus
from him and I think it's also because
of something anthracite said to me just
like a few days before I played this
game he said that well you can't just
not terraform you have to go for the
bonuses you have to terraform a little
bit because you have to get your points
otherwise you're just gonna fall too far
behind but in this case I I don't know I
should not have helped him in the game
because I have so much stuff going for
me this game I'm winning the long game
so I I should have I should have not
cared about this bonus to be honest it's
kind of a theme throughout this game a
terraform way too much I should have not
helped him to close the game so yeah
that's actually the biggest criticism of
myself in this game I I just didn't see
the big picture but these are all pretty
small mistakes I'm okay with these but
now we're getting to the good stuff
let's talk about AI Central what the
hell so yeah Central and two player
games generally good but in this case it
was just way too late it only gave me
six cards and on top of that was just
way too expensive because I also had to
play breathing filters and and Quantum
extracted just to get this down so this
is like I know there's two points on
breathing filters and one on air central
so it's pretty basically what do I spend
like 40 gold just to get three victory
points at six cards I had a lot better
use for my gold at this point I ended up
having a German amplifier in my hand for
six points that I couldn't play because
I spent all of my money doing this like
it makes no sense it's it's really bad
so you know I played the whole game 3D
and I was about to think all right I'm
gonna play Greedy and I'm gonna win and
I almost won by being greedy but in this
case I I'll admit playing playing here
central that was a bit too greedy even
for me it was not a good call and then
we get to the last few generations and I
have way too much stuff in my hand it's
like it's it's very bad how I'm managing
my resources like normally I'm planning
out all right with those two generations
I can play this and this and this and
then I have to sell these fine but in
this case I just kept buying cards I had
no idea what I was doing it was it was
really terrible so I kept large Convoy
and I don't know it's it's good right
because I have like cows so I could use
it on birds or cows or something but so
you know it is a lot of points but I
still have like way too much stuff in my
hand already I've heard it was I'm not
playing I have a German amplifier I'm
not playing for six points it makes no
sense to invest in such a big card now
like like I have it really makes no
sense to me there's even the argument
that I should have actually just caught
ice cap melting instead of just keeping
this large Convoy or even if I keep the
large canva isn't terrible I could just
cut it I could just like keep it in the
draft and then not buy it because maybe
he's gonna get it but it's kind of rough
right because both of these calves will
help him to end the game but the thing
is ice cap melting is just so much
cheaper than Dodge Carnival and yes he
will get five plants so maybe that's
enough for him to get like a free green
read down or something to end the game
but at the same time ice cap melting is
just so cheap so I think I should have
cut that instead of large Convoy and at
the very least it's gonna have more
problems closing the game with large
Convoy so I don't know it's it's kind of
rough it's kind of rough so this is kind
of what I mean when I said that I was
really nervous like normally I would
just look at this hand and be like oh
what are you doing you can't even play
all of this even when I was playing I I
had this like illusion in my head that I
could play the Jovian amplifier and it
didn't even I didn't even see that I was
out of macro it's like holy hell I'm
kind of even happy that anthro said
wasn't watching this game because you
know I could just I could just I could
just feel his voice crawling through me
from across the Multiverse telling me Oh
the misplaced oh the misplaced this uh
yeah I could feel in literally murdering
me through the screen if he was watching
this game um it's good thing he wasn't
watching this game but it's very bad
that I have this huge hand of good cards
and I'm not like realizing the writing
on the wall that there's no way I can
play all of this I'm not even trying to
calculate it it's just completely went
over my head I think it was just nervous
so for whatever reason I was just
completely dropping the ball here it
even then the last generation here like
I talked about with Gods I plenty of
chances to win all I have to do is to
not make this last Greenery let him make
it and then he can't fund an award
even better I could have just started
the feminist or what myself which I
completely missed but you know we can
talk about strategy but the fact of the
matter is I couldn't even read how many
mega credits he had in the last
generation seriously I looked at his
head I I just watched this and I think
what happened dude I kept scrolling
through him and me and I thought my mega
credits was his Mega credit so in my
head I was convinced all right well if
you're close to the game he can't find
an award I don't have to think about the
awards that that's literally what I
thought and then it made no sense to me
when it then happened that he he like he
was able to close the game and thunder
the water I was like huh did he just
play alone how did he get this money
like I just really I literally just
misread how many mega credits he had
left like so you know we can talk about
strategy but basically I just lost my
head there's nothing else to it whatever
so there's probably a few other small
mistakes I didn't catch here but
basically the big mistakes like we
talked about AR Central made no sense uh
making all of this terraforming when
it's obvious he wants to close the game
I was helping him to close the game way
too much that that's what caused in the
game and then of course the big blender
the last iteration where I could have
funded thermalist or at least just make
him make the greenery so he can't fund
anything that's also really weird I
didn't calculate that
I think the thing that bothers me the
most is that I just didn't have any view
of my hand any idea of what I wanted to
do with the cards in my hand like I had
a German amplifier by the end I was like
oh [\h__\h] I should probably play this
Jovian amplifier and then oh I have zero
gold
what what that didn't calculate but but
when everything is said and done this
was a very enjoyable game it was very
fun playing Gods he's a nice guy and I
hope you learned something as well
because I sure did
thanks for watching have a nice day